es handelt sich ja um einen klaren bruch
des völkerrechts rams und wir haben
präsident putin gehört da sind einige
starke worte gefallen
wie ist ihr eindruck dieser rede und vor
allem dieser haltung die e präsident
putin da an den tag gelegt hat diese
rede wirkt auf mich wie eine ich sage
mal durchgezogene begründung beginnen
mit historischen gründen politischen
entwicklungen achtziger neunziger jahren
das verhalten des westens ich sag mal
von 2000 bis in die heutige zeit hinein
um sich auf diese art und weise für die
handlung die er gerade gemacht hat zu
entschuldigen es gibt man halt das
lateinische sprichwort das heißt wer
sich entschuldigt klagt sich an und ich
glaube dass dieser satz hier für den
präsidenten putin
ziemlich zutrifft wenn man die sache von
seiner perspektive sieht ist das mit der
anerkennung dieser beiden unabhängigen
autonomen republiken du kannst ein sehr
geschickter schachzug weil auf diese art
und weise jetzt auch von den beiden
machthabern in diesen republiken zu
hilfe gerufen werden kann und wir haben
praktisch die gleiche situation wie wir
sie vor einigen wochen in kasachstan
gesehen haben das heißt auch hier
wiederholen sich bestimmte dinge die ich
die geschichte auch mit einem anderen
punkt wiederholt nicht mit dem 22 2022
aber die krippen die annektierung der
krim begann am tage nach den olympischen
winterspielen im jahr 2014 das heißt wir
sind an dem selben zeitpunkt wie wir
damals gewesen sind die das ende der
olympischen winterspiele schade dem für
solche aktionen gut zu gefallen haben
sie den eindruck dass die creme annexion
als art blaupause dient für die
republiken lohans konnten jetzt also
sollten sie das oder was heißt
befürchtet aber denken sie dass putin
auch wenn lohans annektieren wird also
er will sie jetzt im augenblick nicht
annektieren das wäre gezwungen geschickt
und zwar so ungeschickt von seinem
eigenen verhalten her aber auch mit
blick auf das verhalten der
internationalen gemeinschaft was seine
handlung aus seiner perspektive
rechtfertige bleibt trotzdem
völkerrechts bruch ist die tatsache dass
er diese beiden republiken anerkannt hat
und dass diese beiden republiken um
hilfe bitten und bei der grafik die
jetzt auch eingeblendet ist möchte ich
mir den hinweis erlauben das was jetzt
tatsächlich in der hand der
separatisten ist oder jetzt der neuen
führer dieser neu anerkannten durch
russland neu anerkannten republiken ist
ja nur die hälfte bis ein drittel vom
leben was diese beiden ob laste
tatsächlich ausmacht und es wird
insgesamt hat das heißt regionen in dem
die regierungen ausmacht und
kein thema und das wird sehr interessant
sein zu sehen um zu beobachten in den
nächsten tagen inwieweit sich jetzt
diese waffenstillstandslinie oder
demarkationslinie auswirkt und ich gehe
davon aus die beurteilung mag fall
schauen es wird sich herausstellen dass
die russischen truppen vorstoßen werden
ist an die richtigen grenzen dieser
beiden regionen und auf diese art und
weise praktisch die gesamten region
gesamten region beide damit in die hand
der jeweiligen machthaber bringt das
wäre dann schon deutlich mehr als das
was bisher in den händen der machthaber
war und dabei lässt sich dann nach
meiner auffassung ein echter konflikt
mit demokratische streitkräften nicht
mehr vermeiden also diese entsendung der
truppen in die separatisten gebiete
führen jetzt wird nicht wird nicht an
der demokratie owns linie oder an der
minsker waffenstillstandslinie aufhören
sondern sie wird weitergehen mit der
absicht die gesamten region unter die
kontrolle der russen und damit auch der
entsprechenden machthaber dieser beiden
nun anerkannten teilrepubliken zu geben
was sind die optionen für für selek er
so kann er was anderes tun als
asylanten und sie lenski kann eigentlich
nur eins machen er kann seine
streitkräfte darauf einschwören diesen
russischen angriff spätestens dann wenn
diese waffenstillstandslinie
überschritten wird nach westen
überschritten wird entsprechend zu
bekämpfen das heißt damit haben wir eine
offene kriegshandlungen jeder beziehung
die nato hat sich ja ganz klar
positioniert und eine drohkulisse
aufrechterhalten die geschlossen ist sie
und wie wir sie sich jetzt positionieren
also eines der größten verdienste von
putin in den letzten wochen und monaten
ist dass er die nato und die eu
zusammengeschweißt hat in der beziehung
weise erfolgreicher dass er
erfolgreicher politik betrieben und ich
bin davon überzeugt und es wäre sehr
schade wenn es nicht der fall wäre dass
diese handlungen die heute stattgefunden
haben
dazu führen werden dass sich sowohl die
nato als auch die europäische union noch
mehr zusammenschließen werden nur wir
müssen uns darüber im klaren sein wir
reden jetzt nicht über nato territorium
von daher hat militärisch gesehen die
nato aus der unterstützungsleistung für
die ukrainische streitkräfte im
augenblick keine handlungsoption wir
wollen jetzt einmal darauf schauen wie
es in der eu aussieht da sind auch schon
sanktionen angekündigt worden wir haben
einen beitrag der uns zusammen warst
auch wie heute nachmittag das treffen
der eu außenministerin und minister
verlaufen ist und florian neuhann fast
das einmal zusammen
kurz und knapp lassen sie uns noch
einmal ein bisschen darüber sprechen was
dieser tag gebracht hat und auch was die
einstellungen des präsidenten russlands
so mit sich gebracht hat er hat ein
zitat war über das populistische
geschwafel der demokratie gesprochen in
bezug auf die ukraine bei der orangenen
revolution 2014 und der unabhängigkeit
des landes
was ist das für ein
politisches bild oder was ist das für
eine einstellung die dahintersteht
sollen bild es eindeutig das bild das er
sagt demokratie ist eine schwache
staatsform ja das ja in seiner rede auch
begründet mit wechselte politikern mit
wechselnden regierungschefs und
dergleichen mehr und er hält die
autokratische herrschaft die er in
russland pflicht und einige andere
menschen in der welt auch noch einfach
für die stärkere staatsform was mit
blick auf entscheidungen
entscheidungsfindung der gleiche
möglicherweise auch manchmal richtig
sein kann denn die demokratie das haben
wir gerade auch bern borel gehört
brauchen sehr lange bevor sie sich über
die sanktionen tatsächlich entscheiden
und die sanktionen in kraft setzen
sicherlich aber der amerikanische
präsident hat heute richtig mit seinem
dekret reagiert er hat die ersten
maßnahmen angeordnet und in europa wird
über diese maßnahmen jetzt erst einmal
geredet dann mussten ministerrat darüber
abstimmen nein das können auch die
botschaft aber entscheiden in
unmittelbarem kurzschluss mit ihrem
eigenen land mit dem entscheidenden land
von daher wäre das möglich und es geht
jetzt eigentlich darum relativ schnell
mit entscheidungen zu kommen mit
sanktionen zu kommen um putin zu zeigen
wir reagieren unmittelbar und sehr
schnell und sehr hart auf das fasten
gemacht was für den russischen
präsidenten wenn das nicht sofort
erfolgt wird das mehr oder weniger zu
einem erfolg und das wäre nicht das was
in unserem interesse oder im interesse
der frauen wirklich sie hatten vorhin
ein lateinisches zitat bemüht wer sich
entschuldigt klagt sich an und wir
hatten beim hören dieser rede auch den
eindruck da spricht ein opfer also nicht
ein ein autokrat jemand der der im
vollbesitz seiner quasi imperialen
kräfte wäre sondern jemand der etwas
bedauert den verlust der ukraine
bedauert er dass rückgängig machen
möchte
das überzeugt dass wir das bedauerten
das hat er ja auch schon geäußert
als er gesagt hat die auflösung der
sowjetunion war der größte fehler des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts das hat er ja
vor einigen jahren so gesagt in der form
und ich glaube dass er vieles bedauert
was mit dem mit der übernahme von
gorbatschow als generalsekretär der kp
de su sich seit 8 985 ereignet hat der
historiker glasnost die entwicklung die
wir gehabt haben die wirklich gute
wirklich um die wie grab da im 90er
jahren als jelzin der russische
präsident war nicht mehr so wird und
wohnen sondern russische präsident das
sind dinge wo entwicklung gewesen sind
die sind aus seiner perspektive in die
falsche richtung gelaufen und er hat
unter anderem in der damals
bemerkenswerten rede im september des
jahres 2001 im deutschen bundestag ist
die tiere ziehen gemäss auch gesagt
andere länder bereiten entscheidung vor
und fällen entscheidung und erwarten
dass russland diese entscheidung umsetzt
ohne an der entscheidungsvorbereitung
beteiligt gewesen zu sein das ist
sicherlich auch für die westliche welt
ich wieder ohne 2001 da war gerade ein
gutes jahr im hand nicht unbedingt ein
kompliment gewesen vielleicht hat der
westen in diesen fragen versorgen
russland in bestimmten dingen stärker
einzubinden um auf diese art und weise
die entscheidungsprozesse auch groß
david beeinflussen zu können denn es
gibt auch einen weiteren alten satz wenn
du jemand nicht schlagen kannst dann
musste ihn entsprechend mit integrieren
das wäre eine möglichkeit gewesen und
vielleicht mit russland haben das
umzugehen aber das ist alles das ist
alles geschichte jetzt ja wollte eine
völlig andere situation
und diese situation hat sich eigentlich
spätestens mit beginn des georgien
krieges im jahr 2008 in dieser
entwicklung abgezeichnet aber
interessant sie sagen 2001 ich meine das
ist eine zeit nach nachdem der deutsch
russischen freundschaft von helmut kohl
ja immer wieder betont hat und auch
gerhard schröder der große schritte auch
auf putin zugegangen ist also da scheint
sich etwas zu offenbaren was vielleicht
putin damals schon eher vorbereitet hat
als dass er wirklich vernachlässigt
worden wäre oder also das kann ich nicht
ausschließen dass er das damals schon
vorbereitet hat er hat aber auch
vielleicht gehofft mit leuten wie
gerhard schröder als als bundeskanzler
vielleicht auch ein bisschen mit unserer
ehemaligen kanzlerin angela merkel
aufgrund bestimmter verständnisse die
die beiden gehabt haben auch weil sie
sich in zwei sprachen direkt dagegen
konnten die brauchten keinen dolmetscher
oder dergleichen dinge mehr ein anderes
verhältnis zu haben möglicherweise jörg
schröder nehme ich als politiker nicht
mehr angst das haben wir verdient aber
das ist so solche äußerungen wie man
sich in letzter zeit gemacht hat mit dem
säbel rasseln der ukraine ist für mich
eine völlig verfehlte sache und
man hat fast den eindruck auch das kann
wieder falsch sein dass putin im prinzip
bei uns auf den regierungswechsel
gewartet hat um dann bestimmte
politische schritte einzuleiten also
angela merkel war ein paar tage weg die
neugier hatte ein paar tage übernommen
da kann diese forderungskatalog am 17 12
auf den tisch woher ein kern gefordert
hat dass sein cordon sanitaire oder sein
konto sieg praktisch wieder hergestellt
würde das drängt sich fast auf wenn man
die zeitliche komponente sie was
bedeutet das jetzt für die nato sie
kennen die nato aus ihrem inneren heraus
wie muss die sich jetzt positionieren
und was hat sie für spielräume sie
sagten vorhin ein zweifelhaftes
verdienst des präsidenten russlands sei
die natur abgeschlossener gemacht zu
haben
also es zeigt sich ja jetzt bereits die
briten die deutschen die amerikaner
dass wir zusätzliche kräfte
beispielsweise in die baltischen staaten
und nach polen verlegen aber auch nach
rumänien das heißt die nato demonstriert
im augenblick ihrer entschlossenheit
gegenüber russland
indem sie die hauptsächlich grenzstaaten
die zu russland beziehungsweise
weißrussland unmittelbar an der grenze
liegen mit truppen verstärkt wir müssen
uns darüber im klaren sein wenn wir über
100.000 und 150.000 russische soldaten
reden dann sind die paar tausend die
jetzt von der nato dahin verlegt werden
der berühmte tropfen auf den heißen
stein ich bin ja gesagt aber es ist eine
symbol handlung die eindeutig sagt die
eindeutig sagt wir wollen nicht wir
wollen nicht zulassen dass sich ein
solcher konflikt dann auch noch
ausweitet auf nato territorium
ich danke ihnen erst mal soweit herr
sams wir haben noch weitere gespräche
vorbereitet und die schauen wir uns
jetzt an
herr rams wir haben jetzt einige stimmen
gehört einige einschätzungen auch aber
was bedeutet diese truppenverlegung
diese verschiebungen was bedeutet das
alles für die zivilbevölkerung
also wir wissen dass in dem teil der
züge in autonomen republiken gehört und
bisher ostwärts der
waffenstillstandslinie sagt lag im
größerem umfang
zivilisten evakuiert worden sind nach
wunsch und nach rostov am don
diese evakuierung die ihr angeblicher
feucht ist aufgrund von erwarteten
angriffen der ukraine über die
demokratien der aktionslinie hin bekommt
für mich heute ein völlig anderes licht
dort hat man die zivilisten weg gebracht
damit sie bei einem angriff der
russischen streitkräfte der dann
wahrscheinlich irgendwann in den
nächsten tagen oder vielleicht schon
morgen erfolgen wird nicht entsprechend
verwundet verletzt oder getötet werden
eine ähnliche bewegung der bevölkerung
ist auf der westlichen seite der
waffenstillstandslinie bisher nicht der
feuchter beim kenntnisstand zumindest
kenne ich keine begriffe berichte
darüber so dass ich damit rechne dass
ich in der heutigen nach spätestens aber
morgen aus diesem teil der ukraine
bevölkerung in richtung westen in marsch
setzen wird und dass das fasse lenski
auch bei seiner rede in münchen mit
beschworen hat und andere staatschefs
auch von gesprochen haben beispielsweise
die polnische seite dass wir eine
flüchtlingsbewegung aus der ukraine
herausbekommen werden aber zumindest in
der ukraine von ost nach west
er habe stimmen gehört die forderung
nach dem nach einer sitzung des des
un-sicherheitsrates wie wie ordnen sie
das ein was sind da die nächsten
schritte also wir wissen alle dass der
un sicherheitsrat
wahrscheinlich sehr schnell
zusammenkommen wird man solche forderung
von mehreren nationen gestellt werden
ich gehe davon aus dass der russische
botschafter bei den vereinten nationen
hier versuchen wird alles abzublocken
für mich wird interessant seien auch
nach der rede des chinesischen
außenministers am sonntag bei der
münchner sicherheitskonferenz über
virtuelle wissen
welche position china dabei beziehen
wird denn der chinesische außenminister
hat das verletzten der grenzen der
ukraine eindeutig als ein bruch des
völkerrechts bezeichnet von daher
müssten china ausnahmsweise mal auf der
westlichen seite stehen das wird eine
interessante entwicklung seien die dabei
passiert und sollte es passieren dass
russland dann tatsächlich im
sicherheitsrat komplett isoliert dasteht
dann setzt vielleicht noch mal ein
denkprozess bei putin und bei russland
ein wobei ich nicht glaube dass der
eigentliche renault bringt es ist
interessant dass sie das ansprechen denn
bis vor kurzem stand china immer an der
seite russlands wenn es darum ging im
un-sicherheitsrat abzustimmen denken sie
wirklich ordnen sie diese statement bei
der münchner sicherheitskonferenz
wirklich als so stark ein dass man das
als signal wahrnehmen kann also ich habe
ein fernsehapparat diese rede verfolgt
immer mit den kleinen einschränkungen
dabei wie weit die übersetzung 100
prozent stimmt oder nicht stimmt
entzieht sich meiner kenntnis ich kann
kein chinesisch aber ich fand dieses
statement mit blick auf die verletzten
verletzbarkeit der grenzen und dass ein
solcher eingriff sage ich mal in
irgendeiner form verstoß gegen das
völkerrecht ist schon als ein
ausgesprochen starkes statement kann man
nicht anders sagen da kann auch china im
augenblick und nicht sofort wieder
hinter zurück denn sonst führt china in
der weiteren wird auch unglaubwürdig
vielen dank für diese einschätzung
herr general egon ramms wir werden sie
den kommenden tagen sicher wiedersehen
herzlichen dank nochmal auch für ihre
zeit gerne